- On this episode I talk men and women,
fertile grounds, and wine?
(hip music)
Hey everybody, this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching
the #AskGaryVee show,
Episode 20.
Fun fact about the number 20,
I never thought we'd get to number 20.
- [Voiceover] Steven
asks, "As a man, I find it
"extremely difficult to accept
that other men use Pinterest.
"Any way I can overcome this bias?"
- Steven, there is a way
you can overcome this bias.
It's called stop being a dick.
That's all I've got for you, man.
I'm not trying to razz, probably
trying to get a little time
to talk about the Tres
Picos 2012 Garnacha,
but there's not much to go into it.
I get it, but if you're a man
that is trying to market or sell
or storytell or create awareness to women,
women are spending
obnoxious amounts of time
on this platform.
At scale, a major leader.
If you're targeting 15 year
old guys to 19 year old guys
to sell them sports equipment,
you don't need Pinterest.
But if you want the
audience that lives there,
well then you need to play there,
and your bullshit bias is
surely not helping you.
- [Voiceover] Esben asks,
"How do you get around
"letting a business run
their new social media plan
"by themselves?"
- Esben, we were debating
this question a little bit.
I want to make sure I've got it right.
You know what?
Show Steve real quick.
Let Steve go deeper into, and show Trouty.
Trouty's never been on the show.
(chuckles)
- Oh, you want to go deeper in it?
- [Gary] Well, yeah, I mean, like,
just tell, like, I want to go a little bit
behind the scenes here
because I want to make sure,
I don't want Esben tweeting, like,
"Gary Vee got my question wrong."
I want to make sure you take the blame.
- Okay, fine.
So here's what I thought.
You're asking if you are
a client services company
and you're teaching your clients
how to be better with social
and developing a strategey
for them, how do you prevent them
from just taking the IP
that you've given them
and running off and doing
their own thing with it?
Yeah?
- I think it makes sense.
On the sniffy sniff,
I get a little black raspberry.
Clearly some pepper.
There's a lot of huge fruit,
there's almost like sugar
exploding up with the raspberries.
Obviously a lot of you who've
watched Wine Library TV
in the past know these
kind of wines scare me
because there's a little
oak, it might be over blown
92 points Tanzer, 92 points Robert Parker,
average price 16 bones.
I'm gonna use average price on #AskGaryVee
since this isn't Wine Library TV,
I don't want to give Wine Library's price.
But average price across
the country is 16 bucks.
But an interesting nose fruity
would be very popular with the kids.
You guys like fruit?
- Yes!
- Cool.
See?
Fruit.
People like the fruit.
Anyway, back to the question.
There's a very simple, easy way.
My friend, when I started VaynerMedia,
everybody kept asking me this.
How does your IP, they take it, they run?
(rapid "no" sounds)
This is a continuous game.
I know everything about
Snapchat stories right now.
I know deeply that Vine's
thinking about different things.
I know what's evolving in Facebook.
The best way to keep clients
from not running away from you
after they get something out of you
is to still have something to give.
- Yo Gary Vee, it's Lee Malone here
from YouGotThisBro Festival
on behalf of myself and
of the motivators here
at YouGotThisBro.
Thank you so much for all your
teachings, all your books,
all your videos.
You are the man, there's
no doubt about it.
I love your stuff, man.
My question's really simple.
We speak a lot in schools,
colleges, universities.
We have messages that we want to give out,
we want to help teach these kids,
bring them to a better place, help them
become a better version of themselves,
but the problem is is
for all the following
that we've built up from all the people on
Twitter and Instagram and Youtube
and stuff like that.
A lot of the schools don't
really care about that stuff.
So what my question is is how do I convey
what a following is to people in schools,
headteachers, lecturers, professors,
how do I convey that to someone
who just doesn't care about that stuff?
Thanks man, would really
appreciate your help.
Peace.
- Peace.
Don't edit any of that.
Let the whole thing run.
I love this question.
I spend no time convincing people
to believe in what I believe in.
Up and coming wines,
the internet itself back in '97,
Google Ad Words in 2000,
email marketing in '97,
social today, Snapchat two years ago.
Virtual reality, Oculus
Rift in a couple years.
I have no interest in convincing anybody
about my stuff, so mate, here's
the mistake you're making
that so many make.
They're wasting good time and energy
trying to convince, while
taking that same time
and allocating it to reaching more people.
You need to reach out to
every single school professor
and organization in the
world or your region
or where you want to play.
All of them.
Find the 18 that are intrigued
and spend your time there
versus one-by-one, spending
a week, a month, a year
trying to convince this person
and then nothing happens.
Don't try to convert the unconvertable.
I am thrilled that they don't get it.
Make fun of them after
you're done in a couple years
and say, "Mate, remember
when you didn't get it?
"You're an idiot."
That's fun.
I love doing that.
And that's what you need to do.
So take all your time,
cause that's the asset,
for all of you listening here,
and if you notice, I've noticed
in the comments section,
I'm trying to give
answers that helps anybody
no matter what they do, even though these
are specific questions.
That is the talent I
have as a storyteller.
This is a big one.
Take the time that you
have, that is the asset,
it's the only one there's not more of.
It's the big one,
and apply it to places where
there's fertile grounds.
Go reach out to more grounds to find out
which ones are fertile
versus trying to convert
a nonfertile one into a fertile one.
- [Voiceover] Edoardo asks, "As
the frontman of VaynerMedia,
"your clients must expect to meet you.
"How do you manage that?"
- That's an easy one to manage.
You know, very honestly,
this is a huge misconception.
This company's called VaynerMedia.
Yes, I'm the frontman, but I do not convey
that they are buying me to anyone,
and when we get into new business,
Trouty, you do a lot of new business.
Show Trouty.
Trouty, how often do you find
that people think they're buying me?
- Less and less these days.
- And what happens when
you think that happens?
Well, or when it happens, what do we do?
- We quickly convince them that there are
a lot of smart people behind here
by showing them great work.
- Very PR of you.
(all laughing)
The very simple fact
is I'm not selling me.
We let people know upfront
that there's no buying me.
I mean, look.
The Million Dollar Man in WWF was right.
Everybody's got a price.
You can buy me.
It's just a lot more than you think.
And so we've built a
company, something scalable.
I have no interest in being in every room.
I'm running the business.
I jump into things backbone
all day, all the time
because it's our company
and I'm part of it,
but you're not buying me.
So we just convince them
by telling them the truth.
- [Voiceover] Heather
asks, "Gary, I've watched
"every episode, but guys outnumber women.
"Do you see women and men differ
"on success and tactics?"
- Heather, great point.
Stunman, we need more women questions,
but you can only do what you can.
I mean the truth is, now
that I'm loosing some weight
maybe we'll get some more female fans.
But the fact of the
matter is I really think
that I need more female fans.
No, I think that
I think that there's absolutely no,
it's crazy.
It's so funny how I think about business.
I don't care if you're a corkscrew.
If you've got the guts,
if you've got the juice,
if you've got the ability,
I'm super interested.
I don't see, you know, we're probably
a 60/40 female company,
and we're probably,
more, Trouty?
What are we?
- 63.
- [Gary] 63?
- Yeah, as of two months ago.
- So we're 63% female driven company.
On the upper scale, our
executive creative director,
the woman that runs our
San Francisco office,
up until last week literally
my right hand managing director,
I mean, I don't see any real difference.
One, I'm not looking
for any real difference,
but I don't see a huge
difference of how, you know,
a male or female view success or acting.
I mean, within them there
are differences, right?
Look, nobody's confused that
we're wired differently,
but I haven't really noticed it.
But what I have noticed
is that this wine's finish
is continuous on the pallet.
I'm pretty surprised how long it is.
And overall, it's a pretty juicy wine.
I'm a little bit back, not back.
(indecisive whine)
When I was doing Wine Library TV,
when it comes to fruit
bombs and a lot of fruit,
I was probably a three
out of 10 enthusiast.
Towards the tippy end,
got into Daily Grape,
I was probably a 4.5,
so it started growing.
I'm probably in that
same 4.5 vein right now,
but, as you saw earlier,
people love the fruit,
and this is a wine a lot
of people are gonna love.
I think Tanzer and Parker had...
I haven't debated with Tanzer
and Parker in a long time.
I think Tanzer and Parker
are being a little bit
generous with 92 point scores.
To me, this is more of an 89 plus, but
for a barbecue wine,
football season's here,
at a tailgate, this is one juicy...
effing wine.
I didn't want to curse.
It's funny, when I'm in Wine Library zone,
I don't want...
It's so weird, the brain is crazy.
Guys, the brain is crazy.
To me this is a great wine and
it's nationally distributed,
you should be able to find it.
89 plus GV score on this little bad boy.
Good fruit, good pepper, good balance,
just a little too fake juicy, almost like,
too much makeup, and I don't like that,
I like the, yeah.
Question of the day.
What is your favorite food
to bring to a tailgate
and, and I appreciate yesterday because
I'm getting so much feedback,
it's helping the show.
Continue to give me feedback.
Lurkers, thank you so much
for coming out yesterday.
I'll take more of you.
I appreciate all of you.
You keep asking questions, I'll
keep trying to answer them.
(hip music)